تدق صفارات الإنذار من الغارات الجوية فوق
مشهد من المذبحة الماضية
في محطة سكة حديد كراماتورسك.
بصاروخ عليه
شخص ما كتب باللغة الروسية
للأطفال ، كان هناك
أربعة آلاف شخص
ينتظرون القطار غربًا عندما حدثت الضربة
، تسارعت المذبحة من النزوح
الجماعي ، وقد غادر معظم سكان كراماتورسك
المدينة بعد أن حثتهم السلطات المحلية على القيام بذلك.
نظرًا لأن هذا الجزء من
البلاد ، فإن شرق أوكرانيا بأكملها
تستعد لما يمكن أن يكون هجومًا
روسيًا ضخمًا على محطة الحافلات بالمدينة نيكولاي ، حيث كان أحد
المتطوعين يساعد في
إجلائه بالنسبة له ، كانت أخبار انسحاب
القوات الروسية حول العاصمة
كييف حلوة ومرًا عندما  سمعت عن
كييف أنهم غادروا كييف كنت سعيدًا
لأنك تعلم ولكن بعد ذلك أدركت بعد ذلك ببضع
ثوان أنهم ينتقلون إلى
دونباس
أو عن قواهم ، أنا قليلًا ،
لا أستطيع أن أقول إنني مخيف ، لكني أشعر
بالقلق
بشأن شعبي حول الناس حول
الأمهات حول الأجداد ،
بعضهم يتجه غربًا والبعض الآخر شمالًا
إلى مدينة سلوفانسك حيث  لا تزال
القطارات تعمل في
oksana وصديق وأطفالهم
مرتبطون بالحدود في أقصى الغرب ،
هناك الكثير من القصف هنا يقول
أوكسانا إنني أخشى
على الأطفال ، والحمد لله ، لا يزال الأطفال أطفالًا
، ويبقى حفنة من الأقارب البالغين في الخلف
أكثر وعياً بكثير من  خطر المستقبل
[موسيقى]